have you ever felt that it was too late
to do something maybe you always wanted
to start a business or you always wanted
to work in a different profession it
doesn't have to be that substantial
either maybe you just wanted to buy a
house or learn how to fly a plane
but you never ended up doing it when you
originally wanted to and now it seems
like the window of opportunity is gone
maybe real estate has doubled in your
area over the past decade and it feels
like you'd be buying in at the top
or maybe you've been working in the same
career for 20 years and you don't want
to start over from the very beginning
human psychology tells us that there's a
golden time to do something and if the
opportunity is missed it's no longer
worth doing at all
but in reality most of the companies
billionaires celebrities and whoever
else you look up to likely didn't start
at the right time
in fact they probably started during
what felt like the wrong time
so here's the myth of the first mover
advantage
the first problem with the first mover
advantage is that the people who are
actually first aren't actually the ones
that benefit from the so-called first
mover advantage people are so often
worried that it's too late to do
something but rarely do they consider
the possibility of it being too early
and the truth is in most cases it's way
better to be late than early
take starling for instance over the past
few years spacex has been blasting
dozens of satellites into space on a
weekly basis
but this wouldn't be possible without
the falcon 9 rocket which not only
increased the launch rate but also
decreased the launch cost
imagine trying to set up a
satellite-based internet service without
the falcon 9. many satellite internet
companies like vsat and hughes
communications have been building
satellite networks for decades yet
spacex was able to overtake them
overnight because they had the falcon 9.
now you could argue that vsat and hughes
don't get the same funding that spacex
enjoys or that the teams behind these
companies aren't as good as spacex's
team
that could very well be the case with
those two companies but it's definitely
not the case with the teledesk elon musk
and jeff bezos aren't the first mega
billionaires to try satellite internet
that title actually goes to craig mccaw
and bill gates
these two tried to launch a satellite
internet company called teledesk way
back in the early 1990s
they planned on spending 9 billion on
launching 840 satellites and they had
everything going for them
bill and craig were both
multi-billionaire tech founders so they
were able to track the best talent and
all the funding they could dream of
yet about a decade after founding the
company they closed down the venture and
return funding to investors
even nine billion dollars and the best
talent in the world wasn't enough to
make satellite internet work in the
1990s because it was simply too early
and there are dozens of examples just
like this
last year chromebooks were more popular
than macbooks for the first time and
when you consider the cost and
accessibility of chromebooks it's no
wonder they're so popular wouldn't it
have been great if you had the idea to
make chromebooks before google you would
literally be more popular than apple in
the laptop market today
but the thing is larry ellison had this
idea before google itself was even a
thing
if you're not familiar with larry he is
the founder of oracle one of the largest
tech companies in the world oracle was
already massive in the 1990s in fact
oracle was so big and powerful that
larry was trying to bail out apple by
buying the entire company
anyway in 1996 larry launched the
network computer
in contrast to a regular computer the
network computer had very little
hardware it relied on oracle service to
run similar to chromebooks but the
problem was that in the late 1990s the
average home internet connection could
only handle 28.8 kilobits per second
so the network computer didn't make
sense for most people even though it was
cheaper than traditional computers and
oracle ended up discontinuing the nc in
2000
despite coming up with the idea before
google was created and being rich enough
to buy apple larry couldn't make the nc
a reality because it was once again too
early the truth is actually being first
in a market is not always made up to be
you have to guess what the market wants
you have to teach the market about your
product and the required technology and
our market is oftentimes just not ready
for your invention
so while it may be more difficult if
you're late it's often impossible if
you're actually first
and that brings me to the second problem
with the first mover advantage which is
that you never know when the
quote-unquote first-mover advantage is
actually over in hindsight we know that
though companies like google and
facebook weren't the first to the market
they still very much benefited from the
first mover advantage when these
companies were created though these
opportunities weren't nearly as clear
when google launched their search engine
in 1998 it seemed like they missed the
train by a long shot there were several
extremely popular search engines already
on the market like ask jeeves lycos jump
station yahoo autovista and a dog pile
most people would think that the market
already had too many options and that
most of these options would eventually
die off and they'd be right the market
was overcrowded and most of these
options would fade into oblivion but
where they were wrong though was to
think that their first mover advantage
was already over and that the winner had
to be someone who was already on the
market
this isn't just some fluke for google
either
google has repeatedly entered industries
late and dominated nonetheless
google didn't launch gmail until 2004.
hotmail and yahoomail had a seven to
eight year lead on gmail and what about
google chrome
chrome didn't come out until 2008 which
is 13 years after internet explorer six
years after firefox and five years after
safari
if we said that the iphone was like
internet explorer launching google
chrome would be equivalent to breaking
into the smartphone market in 2020
now you might be saying that all of
these examples are within the
fast-moving tech industry and that such
shifts and dominance don't happen in
slow-moving established industries
but that's not really true
it does take a lot longer to establish
dominance in slow-moving industries but
that doesn't mean that it doesn't happen
in fact it happens all the time take the
automobile industry for instance
ford is undisputedly the first to mass
produced vehicles and this was a massive
advantage for them the model t came out
in 1908 and for 21 years ford dominated
the automobile space
henry ford was a genius businessman who
knew exactly how to scale and attract
the best talent
he was one of the first to adopt the
40-hour work week and the moving
assembly line these innovations made
ford cars the cheapest on the market and
thus the most popular
however as world war 1 came to a close
and we entered the roaring 20s people
were willing to spend more on a car and
preferred variety as opposed to the
generic cars that came out of ford
gm catered to this audience by releasing
a new model every year and by 1929 gm
overtook ford as the largest automaker
and gm has never looked back
in the early 1930s chrysler also
overtook ford
at this point though the competition was
heating up between the legacy american
automakers it seemed like regardless of
which american automaker came out on top
america had won automobiles
yet that didn't stop volkswagen and
toyota from being founded in 1937.
at the time 1937 seemed like it was late
to enter the automobile industry the
first mover advantage was clearly over
and entering the automobile industry was
like trying to compete against apple
google and microsoft
but looking back 1937 was still a great
time because there was still so much
growth left
now of course given the slow paced
nature of the industry volkswagen and
toyota didn't become dominant overnight
but eventually in 2009 toyota became the
largest automaker in the world
and in 2017 volkswagen became the
world's largest automaker but the most
ironic part of all of this is that the
highest valued car maker today is
actually tesla and tesla was literally
founded over 100 years after ford the
aircraft industry has a very similar
story legacy aircraft manufacturers like
lockheed boeing and martin were founded
way back in the early 1900s meanwhile
airbus wasn't found until 1970. yet they
just overtook boeing as the world's
largest commercial aircraft manufacturer
as you can see you never really know
when the first mover advantage window
closes because the truth is it never
does
it's kind of like trying to call a top
on the stock market you could be right
for a few years or maybe even a decade
but the next set of innovations and
growth are perpetually just around the
corner and it's just a matter of time
until there's a new leader in the market
and that brings me to my last point
against the first mover advantage which
is the successor advantage
the pioneer of an industry may benefit
from reduced competition more press
coverage and greater brand recognition
but i think the successor advantage is
actually way better first of all
successors benefit from an established
market tesla doesn't have to convince
people that they need a car
there are billions of people who are
looking for a car every decade tesla
just has to convince these people that
their electric offerings are superior to
gas counterparts
on the other hand tesla is the first
mover when it comes to electric cars
and trying to scale up battery
production profitably has almost caused
them to go bankrupt on multiple
occasions
when it comes to electric cars ford is
actually the successor but this isn't
really a bad thing for ford tesla
already made electric cars cool tesla
already made the bad investments when it
comes to scaling battery production and
tesla has already figured out the brunt
of evs
now that the technology is out there how
long will it take forward to implement
it into their own cars three years five
years
they may never overtake tesla but their
eevee journey will be far more stable
predictable and reliable
and what about regulation
it's going to be a nightmare for tesla
to get full self-driving approved by
regulators but once it's approved how
hard would it be for mercedes or bmw to
come out with their own self-driving
packages statistically it's way better
to be a successor than a pioneer
47 percent of first mover companies fail
in their early years while only eight
percent of improver companies fail in
their early years
at the end of the day i'm not trying to
say that first movers don't have an
advantage because they definitely do
starting microsoft in the 1970s and
starting netflix in the late 1990s were
perfect timing and both of these
companies benefited massively from
either intentionally or accidentally
timing the market perfectly
but catching that golden opportunity
often just comes down to luck and some
of the biggest companies in the world
didn't time a single thing correctly but
they're way more successful than their
counterparts that were first movers
the truth is consumers don't care if you
were the first to the market they only
care if you're the best to fulfill their
needs
and if you think you can fill that gap
in someone else's life or your own life
you should take action right now
the best time to plan a tree was 20
years ago but the second best time is
right now
it might feel like you're late but 20
years from now you'll realize that you
were actually early
what's something that you thought was
too late to start comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think the first
mover's advantage is overrated and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one